these guys were part of a process called
the inviction what's it called please
the eviction was a one month experience
where they each had tasks there was 12
people on the eviction
out of the 12 people i whittled it down
to the top three all the others were
evicted from my house
the top three were david lawton and
evans they were the best they were the
hardest working they were the most
sophisticated they were the hungriest in
my opinion at the time
i then lived with david in ireland i
lived with lawton in manchester and i
lived
in london each for one week
during that one week the idea was that
they would become financially free
now if you don't know why i was since
the challenge in about seven months
because i wanted to see how they
performed
would they lose the money
would they sabotage their success and go
back to work at a normal job or would
they flourish and prosper what would
their worthy thing be like what would
their moral companies be like their
efforts how would it be after eight
months it's now being ignorant and i'm
gonna be deciding who will be the
property millionaire and he will
ultimately be the winner of this year's
eviction however i need your help
so i'm going to give each opportunity to
speak and once they're spoken they'll
sit down they'll come up one by one and
then i'm gonna let you guys happily
decide who i'm gonna be working with for
three years to become a property
millionaire question ladies and
gentlemen are you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
well
samuel says i'm like really really
nervous but
this last um like i'm just going to
speak from the heart i didn't prepare an
often i'm not a person to do speeches
but
this last like nine months has been an
absolute roller coaster um
like my journey started back in bristol
2020 uh it was the first ever crash
course i went to
and a bit like everyone here today i
thought you know this is what i want to
do samuel's youtube videos
basically took me to the crash course
and um
we had to sign up for further training i
i actually filled out the form that day
and
you know it was the biggest regret
actually made i
put the form in my pocket and i didn't
sign up to further training so i just i
was kind of one of those skeptics i
thought you know maybe maybe property is
not for me i hadn't really got the money
and um
so i went back to my work
i thought work is a safe place you know
this is where i'm going to make me money
i wasn't happy and um
look july came i was off hired and
you know it's
sorry
like financially
it crippled me um
so october came um
samuel put up a post
uh people applying for the affection
so
look i prayed for a chance i said if i
get a chance i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna turn it down if i didn't
do
the affection i couldn't have done a
financial freedom challenge and
you know the financial freedom challenge
i made
in the first week ten thousand pound and
i never seen that money in my life
and since then i've gone on to
like i've got multiple rent to rent
assays um you know joint ventures i
i combine a house a minute as well um
that everything has just gone absolutely
perfect today's the biggest decision is
going to be in my life in the next 20
minutes and
it's drastically gonna change the course
of my life and
like i i want to do more like money is
just a turn
samuel hit up with video at his crash
course in bristol about the the people
that helped the charity work that he did
um
there was people homeless people they
had no water and i said someday if i had
money i want to do
what samuel does i want to be like
samuel leeds and you know if i won this
challenge today i can do these things so
first and foremost i want to thank
everyone for listening to me
thank you to amelia tony samuel ross
whole family he's been amazing and
whatever happens today is me too
brilliant friends for life evans and
nothing so
thank you everyone
well i just firstly just want to say can
we just give david around and pause
because when he was crying like
i started to cry then as well
um so just by like a show of hands who's
seen like my ff challenge and what what
we did
perfect that's brilliant so like the
challenge itself was
as david said life changing in many ways
i don't know if you know my story but i
was i was employed i had a great job
company car laptop
bloody blah blah i was working so hard
to work up that corporate ladder
to get to something that i thought i
could get to
but quickly i realized that as soon as i
thought i was going somewhere
covered came and i got me redundant i
knew that i had to do something but i
just didn't know what to do samuel came
we did 11 grand in two days
we also went on to finish the week by
securing a piece of land close to where
i live
to build six houses
with a gross development value
of 2.4 million pounds
with no money down
we've now secured
a piece of land in anchorage manchester
city center where we're going to be
putting container ships and converting
them into bed sets
thank you
and making a massive difference
in the town that i'm from
i couldn't do that
if i was still employed because my 40
hours a week would be still employed
still making maybe just 2 600 pound
after tax
now i'm making the money that i'm making
it means i have the freedom and the time
to do what means a lot to me which was
charity i always bought
the homeless guy a meal deal outside
tesco when i seen them and stuff every
now and again but i never could do
anything significant because i didn't
have anything significant to give
anybody i had no money i had no time
now we're earning both i'm earning time
and earning money i can contribute
i said that right did i contribute so
i'm looking at the stage thinking don't
fall off
so that fulfills me as a
person and i just wanted to say you know
thank you for listening to me just
waffle on
hopefully
i inspired you in some way shape or form
thank you very much i appreciate your
time thank you so much
um
so i just want to start by saying that
you know i want to thank each and every
one of you guys for taking the time to
you know to listen to me and you know
david and lauren story i want to thank
samuel leeds um because he has got no
idea what he's done for me but for me
all of this started in october it was
the second of october with my son
playing with ellen
around the house and um you know i was
playing with my son and i was just like
you know what do you want to be when you
grow up where do you want to be and um
you know you named a few things then he
finally really down to being a dentist
and
and um
and for me i was thinking like you know
all the things that you name like no one
of them matched me
um then i realized the reason why he
wanted to be a dentist because you know
he's um his uncle is his mom's brother
uh was a dentist and he used to buy him
all the clothes all the stuff and
everything like that
and um
[Music]
and for me at that time that's when i
realized that i'm officially a loser
um you know my own flesh and blood does
not want to be like me um you know i got
him every two weeks he comes around
ellen's house he sleeps on the bed me
and ellen sleep on the floor and that's
when i realized that evans you go do
something and i'm like you know i go
i'll do whatever i have to do and you
know i started looking for stuff
and you know stamina put the post about
doing the eviction i put up the post for
the eviction um amelia shortlisted me
i did a video i think it was good but i
i text a million on instagram i was like
look man you got no idea what this means
to me and the only way i'm not going to
win is if you don't give me an
opportunity because she had no idea the
reason why i was saying that
and long story short god is good i got
the opportunity i did the eviction um
samuel said i was the work hard probably
all odds were against me to reach the
final i got to the final and um i go to
the defensive freedom challenge and you
know we started the eviction we started
financial freedom challenge first day of
the challenge we got the task you know
uh let's get to renter and secured i'm
thinking like yep i've got some of your
leads the best trader next to me
anything is possible um just didn't go
like that i mean we called agents um
agents was not allowing us in like
coronavirus was like you know forget
this let's drive to agents we drifted
agents went from agency to agency and no
one no one gave us
a rent to rent
the day came to an end someone's like
we're not gonna go home until we secure
insurance
um that didn't happen eight nine o'clock
with no rent hold okay cool let's go and
start the next day the next day came and
before we left the house someone's like
look evans you have to find two rental
runs today if you don't like you pretty
much just fill the challenge and you've
always been you know the villain
starting from zero if you don't make it
happen you'll always be that guy and i
was just like
no pressure okay
um so i made a phone call i made a phone
call direct to a landlord and i can
still remember like yesterday was this
this lady and she was buzzing she was
like yeah we do you know you can do it
you can come round yeah i'm happy come
run have a look and i'm superman my
first phone call is a yes and i consider
them like yesterday we drove we drove to
a house um we packed the car i'm walking
up to the door i'm bumping i'm singing
i'm like yeah this is the one this is
the one and you know i knocked on the
door
and um no one answered
and i knocked on the door again
no one answered i'm thinking okay maybe
she's around the back
knocked again no one answered about four
times then this lady came out
and she was just like what do you want i
was like you know i spoke to you over
the phone i'm evans and she just
completely just gave me a look of this
gus i've never seen someone look at me
like that before
and she looked at samuel and she's just
like was it you i spoke to over the
phone and someone's like no no you spoke
to evans and
long story short she didn't she did not
allow me to come into the property she
dressed me based on the way that i
looked and she allowed samuel to come
into the house and she completely left
me behind and um you know he went out he
went inside he viewed the property and i
was outside and literally that was
literally to make a brick moment in my
entire life i can never forget him and i
was sitting out there i'm thinking like
like i've been on the dock the entire
way the first day i got no rent to runs
and the second morning like the first
lady i met is being racist to me and not
allow me to you know feel proper because
of the way that i look
and um you know samuel came out just
like evans this is the case whatever
and i'm just like what you want to do
and i stayed quiet for a few minutes
but something something was just saying
to me that look evans if you can go for
this
if you can go through this you will
inspire people like no matter what the
obstacle is you can make it happen and
um i was just like is that what you want
to do do you wanna i'm like you know
what some more let's make it happen
and we carried on that day that day we
went to another agent that gave us two
rental rents um aj agent i viewed the
property before calling back and gave me
two more rents around so literally
within a few minutes after that whole
catastrophe i got four renters which is
great
not only did i have the pressure of my
son to you know to become something and
inspire him i had a pressure on my
partner that i kept saying for years
that we're gonna make it baby hang in
there like for years sleeping on this
you know single single bed i was just
like you know what
you know let's just get something i
found a nice apartment in canada off
which she always dreamed about doing um
that we secured that same week after
that i gone over rent to rent maybe 600
pounds i go another one um you know now
my rent portfolio is is just over four
thousand pounds um a month
um i've now
um and i love rental rents and i keep
getting their insurance but i don't i
don't want them anymore so i'm not
packaging them and selling them and on
average i'm making about 12 to 15 000
pounds you know for packaging and
selling deals and doing rent to rent and
you know not only that you know
you know not only that you know i've
secured a very you know a very good
property i'm like i can't sell this and
we pull a joint venture in it's an eight
bedroom property convert it to five
flats we're gonna use a service
accommodation um i make over three
thousand pounds a month i'm not using
any of my own money um but yeah things
were going good i was like okay cool
what do you do now and i was like i mean
you you want to roll evidence you might
you might as well keep going and um you
know last week we secured a hotel
that we're pulling investors in to fund
um that'll make over 15 000 pounds
a month
and
and over the few months i mean i'm a
humble guy from the caribbean man i know
ten thousand pounds is like whoa it's
you know it's a lot of money i've been
making money i've never dreamed of
making um so when i started making money
for doing doing deal selling i started
selling my mom more money because i
always spend a few hundred pound for it
but when i started making more money i
started 500 pounds and a thousand pounds
and all of a sudden she calls me more
often now send me more messages
and um i'm getting more gratitude and i
was just like you know what man
like this is what i'm meant to be doing
i'm meant to be helping people
and um and that's the reason why i come
to all these events to help people you
know when someone comes to me like hey
evan's the reason why i'm here today
i've got quite a few people already the
reason why i'm here today was because
it's because i saw your video for me
that's like that's like that's like
everything and that's the reason why i'm
here on stage and that's the reason why
you know
i feel like i have to go all the way
because when i got started in property i
never knew no one that looks like me
that you know that inspires me right for
me the reason why you know i have to go
all the way is because i know that
there's some people that need to hear my
story there's some people like you know
samuel can't relate to there's some
people like you know ricky can relate to
there's some people like that that needs
to hear my story so they really they
really robbed of an excuse because i'm
not i'm nobody special i'm just somebody
you can copy and paste like someone will
give you the recipe
you know
like whatever excuse you can obviously
have i've had it before and i'm here
making it happen and i couldn't do it
without the support and the training of
some eulogies i want to thank you for
the opportunity to give me so i really
appreciate it thank you so much
[Applause]
his son wanted to be a dentist
like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
the millionaire challenge with heaven
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
can we show some massive massive
appreciation
[Applause]
i just i just i just really want to
thank everybody
[Applause]
i really want to thank you know i really
want to thank david i really want to
thank david you know david has been a
friend you know a friend from day one
really helped me out on the same team um
and you're very analyzed you're very you
know you structure well and that's
helped me a lot so everyone thank you
david thank you so much
and
and i really want to thank i really want
to thank this guy um you guys have seen
us on the eviction you may feel that we
we enemies but these guys helped me um
very very much indirectly as well and um
and um this guy's has forced me to
believe big and this guy uh that's lots
and lots i want to thank you so much bro
you inspired me to think big
i really want to thank you
and um
[Music]
i want to thank
i want to thank one more person i want
to thank two more people
um the person who made this happen
gave me an opportunity when no one
believed in me when he had got no right
to believe in me
you know he believed in me and the way
that he looked at me from day one it was
different i've never seen someone look
at me
the way that samuel looked at me and um
and that's all the belief that i needed
to keep going when everything was tough
just the way that i'm like a
multi-millionaire i'm broke i've got
nothing why is he looking at me like
that but he didn't look at me for the
person i was he looked at me for the
person i couldn't become and i credited
this to you somewhere
and um
i want to thank this la you know the
last person this person you guys got no
idea
what that person means to me um this
person has took me from literally
at the point where i was gonna probably
end my life
um because i just thought i'm not worth
living anymore
i'm a failure
i'm this
person know things were really tough for
me there was a point where i was
homeless and um you know she
she told me to come around you know come
and spend a couple of nights mom
wouldn't know
and um
you know a couple of nights i believe
leading to a couple years
um man i had nothing man i was really in
a bad place and she helped me so
i really want to let you know ellen that
all of this
is because of you um and i thank you so
much
and um
and um you know we've been together for
four years
and um man this has been the toughest
four years the best four years of my
life been through hell and back but
whatever happened to me this person just
she was just like you know she just
couldn't get off like whatever happened
she's just there and i'm thinking like
okay evan she's not like she's maybe
that's a sign and um i mean
you know i just want to
i just you know i just want to let you
know i really appreciate you and um
you know i'll just really ask you know
would it be okay if you allow me to
spend the rest of my life with you would
you mind
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
i mean
i've been carrying the ring around for
the last two months uh today's the one
day that i left at home but i promise
i'll put it on
you know i put i'll put it on tonight
but you know i don't want any of this
success without you because it would not
be possible if if it wasn't for you so
thank you so much for making me the
happiest day
oh my god
i haven't even got financed
it does fit my hands very well
i'm
you